and
morning Rick where are you on my
workbench Morty are you invisible and
you're gonna like fart on me put the
sickle over turn myself into a pickle
Morty pickle rag bunker sorry sorry III
can wait for this to wrap up don't let
me distract you awake off let me say is
it a dream everything in my life they
were--they away option to go back to
sleep hot real shallow Bobby and Suzi
[Music]
welcome to the target here hard
it'll be please okay but not because you
told me kill getting darker we called
the assemble by The Vindicator refused
to answer a literal call to adventure
for you let it go to voicemail
I pulled a genre if you and normal
everything okay here mind your own
business
only Ashok did smart could be this
stupid
Rick and Morty all-new episodes begin
Sunday July 30th at 11:30 at the kill
record Morty the [ __ ] you in front three
only on Adult Swim so then we should see
how many episodes in the next season uh
season three or four oh oh oh not to not
to say that there's a 401 there's a PR
person freaking out right now we have
ten ten good episodes a bag of ten right
yeah okay we finally got a season 3
trailer everybody let's break it down
and there is a new round of that Rick
and Morty merch giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video announce a new
winner at the end of this the darkest
year of them all they break this up over
what looks like a couple of episodes
I'll be interested to see how much of
this goes deep into the season but we've
seen the pickle stuff we saw the
animatic back at Comic Con he gets
himself into a metaphorical pickle and a
literal pickle and falls down into the
sewer so when you're seeing all the
animatic stuff of him sort of hacking up
all the rat him splicing extra things
onto himself and then jumping back out
in this really gnarly looking
configuration that's how he gets himself
out that's his 127 hours and they said
like last season is all about the
effects of Rick on everybody else the
effect of Rick on Morty and how that
changes him now it's all about summer in
Beth's although there isn't a whole lot
of bets in the trailer mostly summer
just going super dark
yeah I'll kill you but not because you
asked me to we got some badass look in
Mad Max fury road I'm going to guess
this is their furiosa right here there's
been a whole lot of shrinking so this
might be them shrunk down on a normal
sized piano but there's another even
smaller piano on top of the big piano so
could go either way in oh man we have
some cyborg summer them infiltrating the
government this might have something to
Phoenix person in the really cool thing
about all the government stuff this
season is that since jerry has been
kicked out and he's been promoted a
whole bunch of times he might show up
during this storyline there are a lot of
theories that he might actually become
the new president just because he Falls
upward so much I've been promoted five
times today and I don't even know what I
did this kind of looks like Chris Pratt
this could be their makeshift guardians
of the galaxy team this giant roller
coaster reminds me of something that you
would see at blitz and chips but it just
looks like the most fun thing ever so
this might be some sort of pleasure
planet and we finally see Jerry I know a
lot of people were wondering if he was
going to get kicked off of this series
permanently but I didn't think he'd be
going anywhere just not inside best
house so obviously the premiere date is
going to be July 30th at 11:30 p.m.
that's normal air time because there was
season 1 footage in this I'm assuming
they're airing at least episode 1 they
might hear episode 2 back-to-back but I
would just expect episode 1 so let me
know what you guys think about all this
let's freak out about this watch it a
billion more times but congratulations
to the latest merch giveaway winner
Connor a plunger please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details everybody
seems to like the merch giveaway so
we'll just keep that going but I'll post
some of the Rick and Morty Live stuff
next it was actually pretty cool I
thought it would be so funny if after a
year of everyone saying when's it
premiering at me saying whatever they're
drying it and then one kid said what
come on where is season 3 and I thought
it would be funny because I happen to
know that that next night they were
premiering it on April Fool's I said to
the kid what do you want me to do just
make it premiere and he's like yeah I do
it all honestly yeah and I'm like fine
just this one time and I thought that
would be so funny and the price I pay is
that everyone now just like come on
another yeah that well we we take so
long that you could do it randomly great
take almost as long as a million monkeys
would take to do it man we yeah it's
tough how do we do it
but that's why that's the main thrust of
tonight is we're gonna
we're going to figure out techniques to
do it better right like we're gonna wear
yeah it's like tonight tonight where we
figure out the real technique UN you and
I are I think you and I would both agree
geniuses and kind of percent are doctors
told us it was true yeah I mean the
special doctors our parents made us see
great place but you know like as some of
us stammer and stutter and overthink
things and others of us a hammer and
underthink thing that and and and so
it's like you know neither of us are the
guy that only does the smart stuff or
the stupid stuff or the you know the
writing stuff for the drawing stuff I
mean you you obviously created and
designed the characters and but now you
have this able-bodied staff of people
that like bring your kid I'm getting
lazier I'm atrophying because of all the
talent surrounding me so while you wait
for everything you can click here for
all my Rick and Morty videos and you can
click here for my non-spoilery
spider-man homecoming review thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]